find the distance between the point
negative two comma negative four this
point right here and the line y is equal
to negative one third x plus two that's
this line right over here
now to do it we just need to figure out
the
a perpendicular line to this blue line
to y is equal to negative 1 3 x plus 2
that contains this point right over here
that contains this point so we need to
figure out
we need to figure out the equation of
this line and then we need to figure out
where do these two lines intersect and
then we need to find the distance
between these two points of intersection
and we have the shortest distance
between this point and this line right
over here
so the first step is to figure out what
is the slope of this perpendicular line
well the slope of a perpendicular line
is going to be the negative inverse of
the slope of this blue line so the
negative inverse of 1 3 of negative one
third is going to be positive three so
this line right over here is going to
have a slope of three so it's going to
have the form y is equal to three x plus
b where b is its y intercept it looks
just eyeballing it here that it's going
to be pretty close to 2 but let's verify
that so to figure out what b actually is
let's substitute this point right over
here we know that not only is this line
slope 3 but it had this point has to sit
on it so this point has to satisfy this
equation
so when x is negative 2 y is negative 4
or we have negative 4
is equal to 3
times negative 2 plus b let me write the
negative 2 in there 3 times negative 2
plus b and now we can solve for b we get
negative 4 is equal to negative 6
plus b
add add 6 to both sides you get 2 is
equal to b or b is equal to 2. so we
were right the y-intercept for the
second line is at 2. so we immediately
can eyeball and or we can verify where
they both intersect they both intersect
the y-axis
at
at what at y equals two for both of
these when x is equal to zero y is equal
to two if it wasn't so obvious we could
set these two equations equal to each
other we could say look we have three x
plus two we know that this is now three
x plus two because b is two
when does three x plus two equal
equal
negative one third x
plus two
well let's see if we subtract two from
both sides when does 3x equal negative
one third x well there's a couple of
things that we could do right over here
we could
add one third x to both sides and then
we will get
three so we'll get three and one third
which is the same thing as ten
thirds x is equal to zero and if you
multiply both sides by three tenths
three tenths
you get
you
get x is equal to zero so these two
lines intersect when x is equal to zero
for both of them when x is equal to zero
y is equal to two
x is equal to zero y is equal to 2. but
you could have eyeballed it here you
could look at you could have seen that
both of their y intercepts which happens
when x is equal to 0 y is equal to 2. so
this point right over here is the point
0 2 we already know that this point
right over here is the point negative 2
comma
negative 4 and now we just need to find
the distance between these two points
and the distance formula really is just
an application of the pythagorean
theorem we just need to find the
distance in the change in the y
direction and the change in the x
direction so let's do that separately
so in the y direction
in the y direction
what is
what is this distance right over here
so we went from y is equal to negative
four to y is equal to two this distance
right over here is six
and what is this distance right over
here well we go from x equals negative
two to x equals zero so this distance
right over here is 2.
so the distance between these two points
is really just a hypotenuse of a right
triangle that has sides 6 and 2. so we
could say if we call this distance d we
could say that the distance squared
is equal to and all i'm really doing
here is restating the distance formula
the distance formula tells you all this
you know y 2 minus you know y 2 minus y
1 which is 6 squared but that's just the
pythagorean theorem that's just saying 6
squared
6 squared plus x2 minus x1 which is 0
minus negative 2 which is positive 2
squared
is going to be equal to the distance
squared but we see that's just the
pythagorean theorem but anyway let's
solve for the distance so the distance
squared is going to be equal to 36 plus
4
which is 40.
and now we can let's see 40 it's
this is so the distance squared or i
could just say the distance is equal to
the square root of 40. square root of 40
is the same thing as the square root of
4
times 10
and so that's the same so the distance
is equal to 2
if we factor out the 4 square root of 4
times square root of 10 2 is the square
root of 4 2
square roots of 10 and we're done